– Hallo! Vielen Dank fürs Kommen!
– Sehr gerne.
Ist alles in Ordnung?
– Ach ja, ich musste bloß rennen,
um nicht zu spät zu kommen.
Ja. Wir beginnen mit dem Unterricht.
Wir haben heute zwei Gäste hier,
die mit uns über das Thema
Flucht sprechen werden:
Inge Kohlhaas und Selma Al-Pascha.
Du, wenn man zu spät kommt, dann
sollte man sich wenigstens entschuldigen.
Schließlich waren alle anderen
hier pünktlich da, ja?
– ’tschuldigung!
– Also,
beide Familien mussten
aus ihrer Heimat fliehen ...
Du auch!
Wenn ich zu spät komme,
dann entschuldige ich mich.
Findest du es in Ordnung,
dass ich den Unterricht
jedes Mal wieder unterbrechen muss?
Das stört alle.
– Entschuldigung.
– Also mir reicht’s langsam, ja?
Diese ständige Unpünktlichkeit
ist absolut inakzeptabel
und überhaupt kein Grund zum Grinsen.
Setz dich!
Können wir jetzt weitermachen?